I'm saying nothing because you've all
exhausted every expression you have so
it's a great honor and a pleasure for me
to present to you the five elegant and
talented women who are nominated for the
best achievement by an actress this
evening they are Cate Blanchett and
Elizabeth Fernanda Montenegro in Central
Station
when it's Paul TRO in Shakespeare and
love
maril Street in one true thing
Emily Watson in Hillary and Jackie
and the Oscar goes to Gwyneth Paltrow
when it's cultural
appeared in nearly 20 film including
Emma and
or get this work
I would like to thank the Academy from
the bottom of my heart
um I would like to thank Emily Watson
and Fernanda Montenegro and my friend
Cate Blanchett and the greatest one who
ever was Meryl Streep I I don't feel
very deserving him this in your presence
but I would like to thank Harvey
Weinstein and everybody at Miramax Films
for their undying support of me I would
like to I wouldn't I wouldn't be in this
auditorium let alone up here if it
wasn't for two incredibly talented men
our director John Madden thank you so
much for all that you gave me you were
so inspiring and into my soulful partner
Joseph Fiennes who I share this with I
wouldn't be here without him um I'd like
to thank the rest of our miraculous cast
and crew our producers Donna gelati and
David Parfitt I didn't forget you this
time and especially Jim McGill um and so
fush and and my friend Ben Affleck and
um I would like to thank my wonderful
agent Rick
Kurtzman who is a beautiful man and a
wonderful agent and in his case that is
not an oxymoron and I would like to
thank Harold Brown Stewart Gale warg and
Stephen you vane um I would not have
been able to play this role had I not
understood love of a tremendous
magnitude and for that I thank my family
my mother Blythe Danner who I love more
than anything and my my brother Jake
Paltrow who is just the dearest person
in the whole world my earthly guardian
angel Mary Wigmore um and has been to my
father Bruce Paltrow who has surmounted
insurmountable obstacles this year I
love you more than anything in the world
and to my grandpa Buster who almost made
it here tonight but couldn't quite get
here
a grandpa I want I want you to know that
you've created a beautiful family who
loves you and loves each other more than
anything and we thank you for that I
would like to dedicate this to two young
men who lost their lives very early
Harrison Kravis and my cousin Keith
Paltrow we miss you very much and I
thank you thank you so much everybody